Last Man on Earth, I wanna ask you about this.
One of the things that I love about the show
is that you'll bring celebrities on,
celebrity cameos to have,
and then they kill them almost immediately.
Yeah.
You guys did that
with Will Ferrell.
Yeah, my character killed Will Ferrell.
Spoilers for those of you streaming.
Whatever.
Jack Black.
Dead.
Yeah--
Yeah.
(laughs)
Who do you want?
Is there a cameo that you want,
you wanna have a star come on?
And they're actually pretty funny deaths.
When they've happened, they've always been really funny.
Is there a celebrity you're looking for,
you'd love to have on for a cameo death?
Oh, Conan, I'm always pitching for Beyonce
to come on the show and it's just falling on dead ears.
She's not interested, but I--
I don't think she wants to come on a show
and just get killed right away.
But I would give her, it's my show,
I would give her a very long death scene.
And that's a privilege to play.
Everybody wants to milk that.
Yeah.
And you haven't heard back from her yet.
No, I haven't asked.
I'm asking her now.
(audience laughs)
Beyonce, I know you watch Conan every night.
Yeah, Beyonce never misses a Conan.
Yeah, and I know you stayed until after Tracy,
so why don't you be on the show?
Unless it gets canceled,
then everyone write your congressman 'cause it's--
(audience laughs)
It's on the bubble!